bautizado con el nombre del compositor
favorito de Hitler el grupo paramilitar
Wagner fue fundado y es dirigido por el
Estrecho Aliado de Vladimir Putin y
afganishing el kremlin negó durante
mucho tiempo la existencia del grupo
pero ahora cumplen un rol primordial en
la guerra ucraniana lejos del hábitat
natural del grupo en África de Sudán a
Libia Chad a Guinea incluso Madagascar
Los mercenarios habrían operado en más
de una docena de países africanos según
el centro de estudios estratégicos e
internacionales el modus operandi de
Wagner es ahora bien conocido a cambio
de sus servicios saquea los recursos
locales como en la República
centroafricana y Mali donde se han
apoderado de minas de oro el resultado
es una ganancia financiera en
cuantificable que ayuda a financiar las
operaciones del grupo en Ucrania y pagar
a sus combatientes acusados de
violaciones y torturas en varios países
africanos el grupo también está presente
en Venezuela y Siria últimamente su
importancia ha crecido en Ucrania al
igual que la de su líder yin así como su
frustración con el mandato militar ruso
al que acusa de no estar a la altura
tenemos una escasez de municiones del
70%
Dónde está la munición
dice que sus hombres han sufrido grandes
pérdidas y suministros inadecuados de
munición
particularmente en la batalla por bakmut
la más larga y Sangrienta de la guerra
su número de combatientes es desconocido
decenas de miles de convictos fueron
reclutados en sus filas de las cárceles
rusas pero el jefe del grupo dice que
otros tantos murieron en el campo de
batalla hinchando los cementerios
dedicados a ellos el pasado noviembre el
Grupo Mercenario salió de las Sombras
abriendo un importante cuartel general
en el centro de San Petersburgo la
ciudad donde prigollín y Putin se
conocieron el edificio también alberga
otra de las actividades de Wagner sus
servicios de propaganda al kremlin una
granja de trolls que emplea a miles de
soldados digitales el segundo ejército
de Jean y pregolín